Movies are like games of Jenga: if just one piece
is out of place, the entire thing collapses,
no matter how well built the rest of it is.
Even movies that otherwise were great have
been ruined by a bad decision. Here's a look at
movies that were destroyed by just one scene...
The Dark Knight Rises was full of
little head-scratching moments,
such as "If the villain's plan is
to blow up Gotham after holding it hostage,
why does he wait all those months to do it?" Most
of these you can just let slide, but the reveal of
Joseph Gordon-Levitt's real
identity?
That's...that's just too much.
You know, Robin! Of course, in the comics,
Robin's real name is Dick. Or Jason. Or Tim. Or
Damien. Or even Stephanie. But apparently any
of those names would have been too subtle
for movie audiences, so they hit you over
the head instead. It's like revealing this
dude's name is "John Aquaman" or something.
At the climax of Christopher Nolan's sci-fi
epic Interstellar, Matthew McConaughey's pilot
character falls into a black hole and lands
inside a far-flung future device that lets him
send cryptic messages to his daughter in the past.
Or in other words, he has to use some hippy-dippy
Morse Code machine to save the future
using — that's right — the power of love.
"No, no, no, no, Murph!! MURPH!!!! No! No!"
Really? Love? That's the secret
to unlocking the mysteries
of the time-space continuum?
"Great Scott!"
There was a minute there where it looked like
Ridley Scott's Prometheus was going to be one
of the coolest movies ever made. But what
it turned out to be was a slow exercise in
cluelessness. Plenty of fans either love it or
hate it, but it's hard to argue about that one,
sequence where the characters have to
avoid being crushed by a rolling spaceship.
It looks tense, exciting, thrilling
even — right up until you ask yourself:
why didn't they just move to the side instead of
trying to outrun it? In fact, the main character
lives simply by rolling three feet. Now if only
she had told her buddy to do the same thing,
maybe we wouldn't have left the
theater feeling profoundly stupider.
Throughout the majority of 12 Years a Slave,
the story of Solomon Northup, a free man who
was kidnapped and forced into slavery, is artfully
told through brutal visuals and compelling
performances. Then Brad Pitt shows up.
And he speaks, using whatever that accent
this was supposed to be, with his Brad
Pitt acting and his Brad Pitt face:
"Freedom is everything. The fact that I can even
walk out here tomorrow brings me great pleasure."
Uh...start walking, Brad. That
would give us great pleasure.
Let the Right One In is a rare kind of horror
movie, a haunting character study with few
loud moments or overt scares. It is, simply
put, an excellent, creepy flick. But it does
have one massive, unintentional belly
laugh moment that kinda ruins it...
*screams*
Here's a free tip to any future
horror movie directors. If you
want to keep your audience terrified,
and on the edge of their seats, just skip the evil
attack kittens. Kittens can't really pull off the
evil thing, y'know? They're just too damn cute!
"I'm going to kill you!"
In 1997, fans were excited at the chance to
see the remastered Star Wars trilogy on the
big screen. And then...this happened.
"I bet you have."
In an instant, people realized
George Lucas hadn't improved the
series with the Special Editions.
He'd ruined it. The collective
scream of distraught fans is still
reverberating around the universe.
"I felt a great disturbance in the Force. As if
millions of voices suddenly cried out
in terror and were suddenly silenced."
Well...maybe not exactly "silenced."
Now, you can almost understand the thought
process behind having Greedo shoot first.
But for every revision Lucas has explained,
there are at least three others made to the
trilogy are just random and bizarre. And none of
them are more random, or more bizarre, than the
insanely stupid "Jedi Rocks" dance number in the
middle of Return of the Jedi. Prepare yourselves:
"I have a very bad feeling about this."
(horrible music playing)
"No!"
"Nooooo!
No!"
"I don't really have a lot of
awards, to be very honest with you."
To say that Peter Parker's dance scene ruined
Spider-Man 3 is a bit of an exaggeration,
since there's so much more wrong with the film.
The misfired Sandman CGI, the underwhelming Venom,
and James Franco's pie-eating performance all
contributed to the flop that was Spider-Man
3. But all of that pales in comparison to Peter
Parker dancing at the jazz club. Tobey Maguire's
awkward hip-thrusting and finger-snapping as
he gazes through his messy bangs play more
like a bad SNL sketch than anything that ever
should have made it into a superhero movie.
"Now dig on this."
How many people choked on their popcorn when he
actually said that? Because
seriously. That's awful.
The scene where Neo fights a crapload of Agent
Smiths was supposed to be one of the major action
set pieces for The Matrix Reloaded. But the second
the fighting begins, both Neo and Agent Smith get
replaced with CGI so terrible it makes The Sims
look like virtual reality. The scene was meant to
follow up the groundbreaking "bullet-time" effects
of the first movie. Instead, the botched effects
proved to audiences that neither Matrix sequel
would even come close to touching the original.
John McClane has done a lot of wildly
unrealistic things in his accidental
encounters with terrorists. But none have even
come close to single-handedly fighting—and
beating—an actual fighter jet. Live Free or Die
Hard is far from the best movie of the series,
but it was still pretty good even after being
watered down from an R-rating to PG-13. That is,
until the filmmakers just said, "eff it," and
went to crazytown in this scene. There's the
laughable ease with which a hacker takes command
of the Marine jet, to the Rube Goldberg-esque way
the highway perfectly falls apart to let McClane
escape, the entire scene should've stayed in the
imagination of the six-year-old who thought
it up. Also, how is McClane able to drive
a semi? You know what? Never mind. That's
actually the least ridiculous thing here.
With the help of a parachute, a piece of a
plane, and video effects that would embarrass
a high school A/V club, James Bond surfs on what
appears to be a hundred foot wave of arctic water
in Die Another Day. This single scene has been
cited as the death knell for Pierce Brosnan's
Bond. It also sent the entire franchise back to
the drawing board to reimagine the character and
the entire franchise. It took four years and the
casting of Daniel Craig for the series to redeem
itself from that time a James Bond movie looked
like it was ripped from a PlayStation 2 video
game cutscene. But we'll never forget. Your
Bond died that day, Pierce. Make no mistake.
Of the many things that catch blame for
"ruining" the Star Wars prequels—Jar Jar Binks,
midi-chlorians, almost every line
of dialogue George Lucas wrote for
Padme and Anakin—there is one moment
that makes almost every fan cringe,
no matter how dedicated. We're talking about
Anakin Skywalker's charred transformation into
Darth Vader, literally the jumping-off
point of the entire Star Wars saga.
In this moment, Vader learns he's lost
his wife and unborn children...and
has been transformed into, like, a Space
Robocop. So, what does he do? He does this:
“Nooooooooooo”
It felt silly when it should have been
tear-jerking, and it capped a performance
by Hayden Christensen that was so unlikeable
that he went from that guy poised to be this
generation's Harrison Ford to the guy who was in
that bank heist movie with Chris Brown and T.I.
If you ever found yourself being attacked by
a velociraptor, you'd probably wet your pants
and run away screaming. With that in mind, it's
impossible not to lose total faith in Jurassic
Park: The Lost World when Kelly Malcolm,
the spunky daughter of Dr. Ian Malcolm,
stands her ground against one of the lethal
dinosaurs by putting her gymnastic training to
the test. Watching a kid hold her own against
one of the franchise's nastiest villains is
undeniably cool, but the way she does it—hauling
off and kicking the creature through a window—is
entirely unbelievable. Sure, this is a movie
about about dinosaurs being brought back to
life. But dino-fighting-gymnastic
skills are just a bridge too far.
The Lord of the Rings trilogy's leisurely
pace is part of its charm. When you watch
one of these movies, you know you're settling
in for a truly epic adventure. But even by
those standards, the concluding
chapter, The Return of the King,
goes on for what seems like forever—especially
in the final act, which seems to have, like,
four or five endings. It's always hard
to say goodbye to a great cinematic saga,
so we can't begrudge director Peter Jackson his
fond Frodo farewell. Except for the scene where
the Hobbits frolic on top of a bed in gauzy light
and slow motion. After spending all those hours
with Frodo, Samwise, and the rest of the gang,
we want to be laughing with them. Not at them.
Most people have never gone to a Transformers
movie expecting a sensible plot or characters
worth caring about. We line up for these things
for awesome special effects, and director Michael
Bay is more than happy to deliver. Unfortunately,
Bay isn't always content to just blow stuff up.
Sometimes he wants to be funny, too. And that's
what led to the introduction of Skids and Mudflap
in Revenge of the Fallen. Forget about robots in
disguise: these two are racist caricatures out in
the open, trading on every offensive stereotype
in the book. Bay later tried to throw the voice
actors under the bus by blaming the characters'
demeanor on faulty line readings, but no one
bought it. Skids and Mudflap were even cut from
the next movie in the franchise, Dark of the Moon.
By the time Indiana Jones and the Kingdom of
the Crystal Skull arrived in 2008, we'd been
waiting for a new Indy adventure for nearly 20
years. Almost nothing could've killed our buzz
for getting to spend another two hours with our
favorite archaeologist. In the end, while it's
no one's favorite Indiana Jones movie, most folks
were willing to forgive most of its flaws—except
for the infamous "nuking the fridge" sequence.
Even in a movie that asks us to suspend our
disbelief far enough to accept Indy making contact
with aliens, this awful action set piece—which
finds Indy miraculously surviving a nuclear
test blast by using a lead-lined refrigerator
as shelter—is laughable, and ranks as one of
the few true missteps in a beloved franchise.
The first four Superman movies
weren't all great films by any means,
but they had a certain sweetness about them
that reflected the character's optimism in
the comics. All that changed when Zack
Snyder took the reins for 2013's Man of
Steel. Although darker overtones were probably
to be expected in the post-Dark Knight world,
it was still difficult for many longtime fans to
accept the rampant, casual destruction Superman
helped unleash during his battle with Zod in the
final act. Even harder to accept was his decision
to end the fight...by snapping Zod's neck. Snyder
has defended his decision repeatedly, but that
plot point remains the focus of intense debate.
For some fans, it undermines the entire concept
of the character, and when they saw it go down in
the theater, they had one unavoidable reaction: